mr wilson what can you tell us about the
known facts of the crack speed you know
behavior
let me start off by saying this is a
very tragic and sad day in this
community
a woman lost her life
another person perhaps lost his career
and is perhaps going to prison
uh this was a very very ugly day
yesterday morning
how do you feel about the bail being set
at 150 000 instead of one million
you know a bail is determined by a judge
and the judge heard both arguments from
both sides and i respect the judge's
decision
do you have any details on the victim as
of right now
i believe it's a 23 year old female
i don't believe she's married or has
children
what message does this bring out that he
hired a high profile attorney he has a
clean record but he will most likely
make bail and
bri be free until you know he has to
come back to court again
life is about choices
mr ruggs made a choice
and the difficulty i have is there's so
many alternatives there's ride sharing
there's a designated driver there's a
taxi there's so many alternatives but mr
ruggs made a choice
and he's going to have to live with the
consequences
you know i just met the family this
morning the families torn apart
as anybody would be this was a terrible
terrible
collision
so they're
mourning their loss they're grieving
they're mad
they have all of the emotions you would
think a family would have
have you heard anything about the race
or racing or do you think mr ruggs was
driving on his own do you know any of
those facts you know this is an ongoing
investigation
this accident this collision
just occurred two days ago so it's an
open investigation
metro's investigators are still
investigating all of the facts
my understanding is there may have been
other people with mr ruggs earlier in
the evening and all of those things are
going to be looked into
what do you think his attorney's
motive is to hold their own
investigation
attorneys have jobs to do
i've done a number of cases with a
number of lawyers mr ruggs has good
lawyers they have the right to conduct
their own investigation uh let them um
but we've conducted our investigation
and the facts are pretty strong at this
point
suspected of impairment can you
elaborate on that there's a suspected
album there's no more suspect anymore
there's no more suspicion his blood
alcohol level came out
his blood alcohol level came back at
0.16
that's twice the legal limit
mr ruggs made a choice to drive while
under the influence and be twice the
legal
limit and justice said that this is one
of the fastest feeds that they had seen
in their career is this also
an incredible i've never seen a case
in my 41 years here in las vegas
of a person who's charged with a crime
driving in excess of 150 miles an hour
sir obviously ruggs is a football player
local team are you looking to make an
example and show that even though you're
of that status and above the law in any
case like this
mr ruggs is no different than anybody
else whether you're an athlete whether
you're a police officer visiting from
out of state whether it's you kyle i
don't care
like i said before it's about choices
and if somebody chooses to drive while
under the influence and drive in excess
of 150 miles an hour
we're going to seek justice
this community needs to understand
that driving while impaired is a serious
matter
like i said in the beginning of this
conference this is a tragic and sad day
it's a tragedy because a woman lost her
life and a lot of other people are
suffering it's also sad and tragic that
mr ruggs is potentially losing an entire
career and facing a stiff prison
sentence
that's the message the message is use an
alternative make a good choice
don't drink while impaired i'm sorry
we're exploring that right now it's only
a two day old investigation
the evidence shows that a
handgun was found on the floor board
where mr ruggs was driving so we are
going to explore that charge can you
elaborate on that do you know if it was
in a case or if it was just unsecured i
don't have that information
mr wilson seems like we're always
talking about the same issue is there
anything else we can do perhaps harsher
penalties for these type of offenses
seems like a
non-stop problem
well we tried
uh months ago we filed murder charges in
a case very similar to this
where there was excessive and reckless
driving
but the nevada supreme court said that
was inappropriate and we accept that
but there is the next legislative
session
because think about the behavior in this
case and so many other felony dui death
cases a person makes a choice
minutes or hours before the collision
to consume alcohol
and then drive recklessly
that person faces a lesser punishment
than a person who's convicted of murder
who may decide to kill somebody in just
a few moments
so in my opinion we need to look at
increasing the punishment for felony dui
cases
are you able to identify the victim yet
no
do you know where mr rose was coming
from
the evidence suggests that he was coming
from top golf
and then i think that there's some
evidence to suggest after topgolf they
went over to a friend's house but i'm
not
positive there was mention that there
might be
charges filed for the trans female
passenger do you know if they're going
to be moving forward with that yes it's
my understanding that she suffered what
is called under the law substantial
bodily harm
we are reviewing the evidence right now
if it qualifies there will be a second
felony dui charge
mr mr attorney does
she face any criminal
culpability in this case no
would you identify her as her
relationship with mr ruggs it's my
understanding she was his girlfriend do
they have a child together that's my
understanding they do and the judge was
would that be the same judgment
that the judge referred to as a
three-year-old
i'm not sure
i understand he sustained some leg
injuries i'm not familiar with any of
the specifics
can you elaborate
i've been told that she had a
significant wrist injury that required
surgery but i'm not positive
and right now we have dui resulting in
significant bodily harm and reckless
driving resulting in death you have to
understand
he's only been arrested and booked
next wednesday you will learn what
charges are filed we are looking at
charging him with two counts a felony
dui and an account of reckless driving
and we're exploring whether or not the
evidence supports any charges with
regard to the gun can you explain the
rationale for the second dui
yes the law says if you
drive while under the influence and
cause either death or substantial bodily
harm to another person
it's a separate count so the passenger
in his car who was maybe substantial
substantially bodily injured that may
give rise to the second count
what's the punishment range for those
offenses two to twenty years in prison
for reckless no reckless is one to six
felony dui is two to twenty each
no with enhancements no that there is no
enhancement
felony dui causing death or substantial
bodily injury so for the young woman
that lost her life that's one count for
the passenger that's a potential second
count
it was mentioned
it was mentioned that he was
uncooperative uh towards police can you
elaborate on that what was his demeanor
what he said he wasn't the most
cooperative person while at the hospital
but i'm not going to elaborate
are you able to just recap given the
charges we're considering what would be
the minimum total and the maximum total
charge uh years he's facing
well the minimum would be two years the
maximum would be 46
and that could increase depending on
whether we file an additional charge
involving the gun